man muss einfach viel planen und sich
viel überlegen aber das ist mittlerweile
mein hobby geworden einfach
zeitmanagements
[Musik]
eine mit solist war dann heißt es
wirklich kaum vertrauen vom volk aus
bretten solingen zum blitzen
[Musik]
was nehmen eltern auf sich um ihren
kindern träume zu erfüllen und worauf
müssen sie deshalb verzichten
das wohnzimmer der familie pro familia
im aargauischen hunzenschwil die vier
kinder trainieren für den nächsten
wettkampf adriano tiziana nina und die
älteste tochter valentina alle sind
sportverrückt drei stunden training pro
tag sind keine seltenheit vater girardot
kümmert sich um die ausrüstung selbst
einmal bei historisch aber irgendwann
entlädt und so der ganghofer und sage
ganz aus aig zu bieten den ist auch der
turbo se gehört will wenn ein kind ein
konflikt an
was ist konfliktpotenzial ist relativ
groß vor allem ab mit ein paar velos im
keller hat alles begonnen
inzwischen ist der keller ein
logistikzentrum unter der woche arbeitet
er als it techniker im tessin an den
wochenenden dreht sich alles um die
wettkämpfe der kinder seine eigenen
sportlichen interessen muss er zurück
stellen für die teilnahme an einem
triathlon ist die vorbereitung besonders
aufwendig die bis zu 8000 franken teuren
velos müssen jedes mal sorgfältig
überprüft und neu eingestellt werden
muss man immer alles funktioniert hat
celtic richtige ist
bremsen indem wir das kabel notwendig
wäre tragisch wenn der nacht eine werdet
mir etwas passiert und dann noch in
einem frühen tor steht oder seien dabei
1000 dort geortet und mit glück zu tun
ist eigentlich lieber wenn es macht also
die mutter caroline kümmert sich unter
der woche um die kinder auch in ihrem
alltag dreht sich alles um sport und die
richtige ernährung
und dazwischen natürlich gibt es das
haus ist auch eine werkstatt für ein
sofa hat es keinen platz
die sache der schulen also dass versuche
der größe und der aggression der strom
musste sie die szenen rufen die nacht
wenn dies das risiko große risse
entstehen da der platz machen
über 600 medaillen haben sich die vier
nachwuchssportler in den letzten jahren
erkämpft und jedes wochenende kommen
neue dazu
die blieben
[Musik]
die story malibu kreis zum gipfel ein
gemeinsames mittagessen dahin ist bei
familie nussbaumer selten
der sohn muss sich oft auf der fahrt zum
nächsten termin verpflegen donath und
pop nussbaumer wohnen mit ihren beiden
kindern sehr einer und raphael in
altendorf im kanton schwyz
der 13 jährige spielt geige seite vier
jahre alt ist
dreimal in der woche fährt ihn der vater
nach der schule zum musikunterricht nach
zürich
heute legen sie einen zwischenstopp beim
geigenbauer in rapperswil 1
raffaels geige muss justiert werden das
talent hat rafael wohl vom vater donath
nussbaumer ist berufsmusiker und spielt
ebenfalls geige
[Musik]
dann kann das manchmal so lange
verziehen
das kräftige die nachricht ich spiele
aber auch und trotzdem im orchester
sogar vor raphael darf probeweise auf
der fast 300 jährigen geige spielen
die suche nach dem richtigen instrument
ist aufwändig und geht ins geld
jetzt wehren hat diesen strom entnehmen
wir fürchten sich frauen kann so dass
dann wird dann auch höchst unglücklich
sie will das instrument er 15 jahre
spricht möglich es gibt echt schlimm ist
also wenn denn hat sich entwickelt und
dann das instrument bremst wird
wilstermann das einfach nicht
das ist ein alter und weisen wir es
gemacht hat wenn man weiß wer es gemacht
hat dann kann es schnell ausbauen
[Musik]
musikspiele ok dem film auch sky es wäre
seine wunsch geige
ob er sie auch weiterhin spielen darf
werden seine eltern in den nächsten
monaten entscheiden
die familie buss wohnt mit ihren drei
kindern in zürich ein paar hundert meter
von der kunsteisbahn oerlikon entfernt
mutter maria bringt ihre buben zwei mal
die woche ins eishockey training fahrt
am laden kommt von der arbeit der
sachbearbeiter verbringt fast jeden
abend auf der eisbahn tochter julia
kommt etwas später dazu schmidt
[Musik]
20 minuten braucht der siebenjährige
nicola um die ausrüstung anzuziehen
vom klub bestimmte eltern helfen den
kindern andere erwachsene werden in den
umkleidekabinen nicht geduldet nicola
trainiert seit zwei jahren beim zürcher
schlittschuh club drei tage schön da in
der klemme weil alle drei kinder
training haben und dann zählen wir auch
ein bisschen zeit genießen aus familie
bleibt erwartet jetzt unter nicht mit
uns und wir schauen natürlich nicola
dann ist nicola fertig die später auf
dem eis und
punktgenau auf bruder und julia kommt
der nahrung die ganz auf training und
das ist so der glaube ich schon wie
unsere zweites zuhause mittlerweile
menschen ja es ist toll dass wir viel
zeit verbringen
nicola zwei trainings blättern hat zwei
trainings da sind vier sind mindestens
zwischen sechs bis acht stunden
manchmal bin ich eben darin die julia
trainiert weil ich will auch sie sind
nicht nur vom piano und da sind noch
zusätzlich stunde also muss - neun oder
zehn stunden pro woche
trainings und dann kommen noch etwas
anstieg so du jede hauptstadt studieren
und mama kommt eben auch gehen wenn sie
keine andere verpflichte gehört weil sie
hat ziemlich viel um die ohren
ich muss euch nicht erklären was sich ja
klar mit drei kindern
[Musik]
neben dem haushalt arbeitet maria als
übersetzerin und in der
kulturvermittlung
sie engagiert sich auch noch in der
schulpflege und koordiniert die termine
der drei kinder
ich mache hier für jede woche meistens
am sonntag oder montag morgen mache ich
so ein plan für die ganze woche
am montag haben die beiden jungs
trainings einfach an verschiedenen nord
und dann müssen wir uns auch selbst ein
bisschen teilen julia zum beispiel sich
hat dann volle nachmittag im training
aber sie geht dann zb von schule direkt
ich bringe ihre sache für training und
kleines damit sie noch etwas essen kann
nachdem schon das heißt diese
wochenendes wird ziemlich aktiv
sie ist immer im stress
nicola erwartet sie julia steht bereits
auf dem eis und das training des
neunjährigen peter ist in vollem gange
[Applaus]
genieße es einfach keine ahnung wie ich
das gerne witze ohne überheblich zu oder
wiegen ist speziell sage oder sollte ich
wirklich so also egal wenn du auf den
unangemeldet rom studie ist mir hier
sehen oder drehen oder liegend weil es
ist auch mein leben jetzt
[Musik]
wenig julias training schauen das ist
für mich ein bisschen entspannung wo ich
wirklich so ein bisschen 17 kann und
einfach nicht machen muss dass muss ich
schon viel wenn es von der zeit her geht
die ersten schlittschuhe hatte julia mit
jetzt ist sie 12 und steht pro woche bis
zu neun stunden auf dem eis sommer und
winter nur mit eiserner disziplin kann
man beim anspruchsvollen training
mithalten
ich würde das nie machen weil ich weiß
dass nicht als persönliche habe aus
meinem persönlichen umfeld dass das
nicht unbedingt gut ist zwar liegen
waren kommen zwei steckend hat keine
chance oder keine keine lust ist nicht
gut
also meiner meinung nach muss selber
gehen und wenn es ihm wirklich so gut
läuft bei ihm
der sport der kinder ist wie die familie
eine finanzielle herausforderung mit
demis roussos lauf kommt man schnell um
die 20.000 pro jahr was sie noch
weggehen für die separat berechnet
werden die man einfach einzahlen muss
dann ist noch ausrüstung oder auch die
julia braucht schlittschuhe sind aber
einem gewissen niveau ziemlich teuer so
bis zu 1000 franken geht es folgen und
die jungs brauchen einfach zuviel diese
sache die sie anziehen und die wachsen
auch fordern und es ist auch so dass man
fast prozessoren eine komplette
ausrüstung braucht um die preis für neue
ausrüstung ist schon so um die 1500
franken durch austrocknen mit dem und
dann geht's an bläser durch sehr schön
einfach frisch verschnitt weil wenn sie
natürlich hier auf gewöhnlichem weg
trocknen dann dann stimmt das meer
warum weiß ich auch nicht aber es ist so
[Musik]
die erfolgsverwöhnte valentina muss mit
16 jahren entscheiden in welche richtung
ihre sportliche karriere geht ihre
eltern reden und planen mit einer großen
floß ich meine sie sind ja mini entsteht
im jahr und gabriele hilft würde ich
sagen ich schaffe aus er sich mal die
finanzielle hilfe mentale unterstützung
ja also diesen job
die eltern besprechen die planung der
wettkämpfe haben wir wohnen ja schon
oder abitur
ja das ist mir da rausholen
während die eltern termine jonglieren
üben sich die kinder in autogenem
training
ich bin ganz ruhig und entspannt körper
und atmet ruhig und gleichmäßig der buch
wien
und frei also haben wir beschlossen dass
die große politik gemacht hatten
da haben wir die sachen und jetzt das
bild vor dem inneren auge und du hast
sie griffen podest standen
vielleicht mitteln die doku yoga machen
und genau so dick werden das jetzt
praktisch identischen kritik vom yoga
oder am samstagabend der
forschungsleistungen wirklich nur eins
und zwei in velen bilder vor dem inneren
auge verschwinden langsam und der hund
wieder zurück und jetzt alles kaputt
vizemeisterin zu schön
milo gehörten immer ganz genau was
machen wir
zehn minuten vor dem start bin ein
wettkampf was möchte dritter im moment
machst autogene training also vorhanden
von staat und der kann mich auch noch
meinen kopf der welt konnten hier
abläuft und baku wäre darüber geredet
ihr tag ausleih und der schafe gebe in
europa einige klubs schon in bremen
gescheitert sieht noch mit der gasse
wenige mikrometer gasse wenn der bin ich
gut und dann in ein geschäft am
hauptstandort unglückliche einfach zum
ich wiederhole
also dort dank ironie gut im griff und
weise mein körper durchdringen zu machen
und ich weiß einfach eine mitwirkung ab
statt mit nämlich einfach aber zwei ganz
familien seit raphael fünf jahre alt ist
besuchte den musikunterricht im
musikkonservatorium in zürich beim
dirigenten und violinisten philipp
dragana eine ausbildung in die seine
eltern viel investieren und die von
raphael sehr gewissenhaft verfolgt wird
soviel jetzt ja okay gut also lasst uns
stimmen
[Musik]
versuch diese erste lange note wirklich
zu entwickeln
jedes detail der beurteilung im
unterricht wird vom vater notiert
und wie viele schläge es
[Musik]
aber dies ist die zweite note zu schnell
ja da und weniger weniger stark und
weniger aggressiv
beim zweiten mal ist es dann schon viel
mehr stolz ok müssen wir leider zum
schluss kommen für heute ja aber schon
sehr gut fürs erste mal beim nächsten
mal aber ein bisschen mehr in die tiefe
ok
[Musik]
es ist ein sehr langer weg alle geiger
müssen früh anfangen mit vier oder fünf
meistens ich denke wichtig dass das
junge leute träumen dürfen dafür bin ich
stehe ich auch immer ein dass ihr sagen
sie sollen sie sollen doch das ziel
haben soll ist oder an ich glaube dann
haben sie eine eine gute motivation aber
muss ich auf der anderen seite auch
bewusst sein dass auf der ganzen welt
nicht in jedem jahrgang ein neuer solist
geboren wird um eine sehr gute orchester
stelle zu bekommen da werden für eine
offene stelle spielen bewerben sich 600
leute wenn einem guten orchester in der
stadt zürich und die kommen aus der
ganzen welt und da muss man auch schon
sehr sehr sehr gut sein und wie oft im
leben im woche das quäntchen glück am
richtigen ort zu sein zur richtigen zeit
um von der richtigen person gehört zu
werden
es gibt viele viele faktoren die da rein
spielen
ob sich das engagement der eltern
gelohnt hat wird sich erst zeigen wenn
raffaels ausbildung abgeschlossen ist
es ist fünf uhr an diesem samstag müssen
vater und sohn sehr früh aufstehen
peter spielt mit seiner mannschaft an
einem eishockey turnier in wien
auch die mutter ist schon wach sie
begleitet heute den jüngeren sohn
nicholas an ein turnier in küssnacht
so sind die eltern woods an den
wochenenden meist getrennt unterwegs
[Musik]
beckham hat
auf teile aufteilen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mac i jetzt super
du bist du partie
[Applaus]
das war einfach monster boss nicht nur
von den nachwuchsspielern wird voller
einsatz erwartet auch die arbeit des
ehrenamtlichen trainers ist zeitintensiv
[Musik]
catcher prozent
also gut bin ich bestimmt von 18 bis 59
stunden bin ich sicher in halle
es ist nie warm oder angenehme china
kalt und in manchen fällen kann man sich
nicht genug gut genug immerhin können
sich vater im laden heute über den
turniersieg seines sohnes mit den zsc
beanies freuen
[Musik]
valentina ist auf erfolgskurs in der
leichtathletik und dem triathlon zählt
sie beim nachwuchs zur schweizer spitze
mutter caroline stoppt die zeit der
abrechnung civil ist nicht einfach wenn
man halt nicht aufbringt verliebt hat
und gerade nach dem römische wichtig in
der göttinger gruppe mitmachen mitfahrer
rahmens crafting erlaubte es rassismus
machen
die vierfache mutter hat früher
ebenfalls leichtathletik betrieben
sie ist die wichtigste stütze für
valentina und ihre erste und
wahrscheinlich ehrlichste kritikerin
bliebe noch
[Musik]
gesetzt einmal der sport als
familienbetrieb in unserem und die als
geplant dass wir immer aus familiären
noch eine hecke und palästina vor allem
jetzt wo sie spaß gemacht aber das ist
ja auch das wirklich leistungssport zu
gott nicht immer neuen dekret ihre
kolleginnen und soße gott sehr gutes
training macht das training relativ sagt
oder und ein konzil cholera und wenig
soziale kontakte und das ist das wo es
momentan beschäftigt und dauerstellen
damals diskussion mit der caroline sehr
den idealen idee das sind die kreativen
phasen wo man mit logen was man das
beste mich frau lisa also familie werde
mir sicher mit jedem hof und 300 bringen
aber das ist mit dem sap eltern oder das
ist zweifelhaft
das nicht so
[Applaus]
[Musik]
richtig
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
während adriano in der musik ecke dampf
ablässt sind seine geschwister mit dem
gedanken bereits beim nächsten wettkampf
wenn wir mit dem ziel nach unten denn
weiß es wird alles geht
denn für mich das beste ist es jedoch
unter dem verdacht ihr euch nicht so gut
gemacht wurde
du machst irgendwie noch um den herrn
ministers chris kraus geht aber auch
bestens machen aber ich glaube man hat
und auch die zwölfjährige julia hofft
auf erfolg für die kühe an der
stadtmeisterschaft in zürich hat sie ein
jahr lang hart trainiert die konkurrenz
ist groß
einfach wird es nicht werden
[Musik]
dass julia siegen kann beweisen ihre
pokale und medaillen
[Musik]
also das ist cool schlechte zweite platz
ich hätte eigentlich der elfte
bouillabaisse isst nichts besseres
michael ossi und denn ich halte ich aber
trotzdem einfach der beste wettkampf
sehr schwierig sich wahrscheinlich der
doppel axel will der handel
da kann ich noch nicht so gut aber ich
hoffe er wird fit kurz auch julias
ausrüstung geht ins geld sparen können
sie weil die mutter die kleider für den
auftritt selber nicht alles da sind zwar
oft gesteine bis zu 1000 steinig hat
sein als heute und die haben schon eine
schöne preis diese dach hat jetzt so um
die 500 steine und es ist sicher dass
die schiris auch schauen wie das
aussieht oder wenn sie so wie die ganze
performance
ich hoffe schon dass sie einfach ihre
doppel axel die sie sich vor knochen
dann zeigen kann und das blut klappt
dass sie nicht stürzt und da sind wir
schon zufrieden
weil es sie schon in der speziellen tag
für sie sowieso aber für mich als mutter
auch weil ich muss dann auch mit ihrer
ihre freude oder ihre vielleicht nicht
so schöne momente
mit erlebe und sie dann auch unterstütze
und größte wenn es sein muss raphael und
seine eltern sind in biel
am abend wird der 13-jährige im
kongresshaus als solist auftreten
er hat seine wunsch geige dabei hätte
worte
sie ist definitiv mini-konzert spiele
mit dem elend spross den kauf der
300-jährigen geige haben sich die eltern
lange und gründlich überlegen müssen
sie ist mehrere zehntausend franken wert
[Musik]
die ausbildung ist immer nur ort und
dann kommt die musik man achtet also die
meisten das musiksystem die die
hochschulen und verbände so formt sich
etwas gedauert aber dann strom je nach
alters gibt es im strom an wenn man
alles zweimal damit ist schon sehr
realistische nach mit und das aber
irgendwie wird mit einem
wiederentdeckten gehört wenn ein spaß
hinkriegen regale für das kostet spitze
nervosität ist stark aber es gehörte zur
verdächtig erschien wichtig eltern sind
sehr große unterstützung
im kongresshaus biel beginnen bald die
proben raphael tritt als solist mit dem
symphonieorchester biel solothurn auf
das konzert wird vom schweizer radio
aufgezeichnet
zu viel aber es passt zugleich das lied
ist und einiges vielleicht trug die frau
liegt und der ton ist intelligent ja
aber diesmal eigentlich muslim metern
oder französisch
[Gelächter]
viel spaß
[Musik]
besorgt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also danke einmal mehr abfahrt zum
wettkampf heute starten drei der vier
kinder am triathlon in wallisellen
für den nachmittag sind nass kühle 8
grad vorausgesagt die rosa milieus sind
dafür gerüstet
jetzt geht's los
minute binya ich liebe 2
die kann man immer noch riesige der
bitten ihnen wird schon schwieriger
die schätzen wir den alltag wo sie alles
besser weiß ja wenn sie den ratschlag
braucht dich und so aber nur und dann
konzentrieren wir uns auf die linie
lenken axel bitte
[Musik]
jeder gesagt und er war sich also wir
mit der ausstand war es aber zur strafe
musste man kann man das littering
kritischen jäger rohstoffs meter wurde
[Gelächter]
so schön schön abtrocknen und leicht
nutzen aus holz stroh sky vision ein
stück auch noch jan o
ja
[Applaus]
stand
warum setzt sich noch eine krone traf
schwimmer hetze zu studieren
die wachstumszone
[Musik]
berlin verpasst hatte erzählte dollar
gehandelt
naja und dem schlaf und traum
die schöne da geht die ca
im schnitt steht dem rennen ist sie also
400 material mythos
bis jetzt konnte setzte die erste und
die zweite einheit minuten locker
[Musik]
zusammen
für julia und ihre mutter ist die
eishalle oerlikon wie ein zweites
zuhause für julia gilt ernst an der
stadtmeisterschaft treten die drei
eiskunstlauf klubs aus zürich
gegeneinander an
vor dem auftritt muss julia die eigens
für die kühe zusammengestellte musik
abgeben
ja
[Musik]
julia
eine letzte aufwärmrunde vor dem großen
auftritt
julias bruder fiebern so oft wie möglich
mit andere familien versammeln sich im
wohnzimmer familie buss 1 trifft sich in
der eishalle
[Musik]
jetzt kommt jetzt jetzt lieber damit
fiebert jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt ernst
natürlich wünscht
er zielt ganz ernst
[Musik]
unglaublich
ich bin gut machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am anfang hat sie zwei mal probiert der
mit zweifach oder wie auch immer das
heißt und dann muss man mit liebe
richtig erforscht die ganze daumen
gedrückt und jetzt ist super drauf und
ich sehr trainer diskrete auch so wenn
trainer politischen sie den kanzler bin
begeistert und sie strahlt und setzt
sich eine wichtigste das sie einfach am
ende von dieser welt kommt dann wirklich
schon freude hat
so brauchen
[Applaus]
in biel muss raffael in einer halben
stunde auf die bühne
[Musik]
wie glück und stahl
mit dem
[Musik]
ich hätte aber die bühne
jetzt ist der 13-jährige ganz auf sich
allein gestellt weil ich kann ich sagen
du musst musiker werden einfach was
erwählt und xl jetzt er hat talent man
sollte einfach machen was man glücklich
wenn er auf der bühne und er sei so
glücklich finde ich viele musiker für
fußballspiele
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hmm
großen aufwand aber es wichtig sich
selber schon dass er spaß damit verliert
der musik und dass ich dann aber diese
prozent
wir verzichten einfach auf teure ferien
jetzt wo sie uns brauchen uns wichtig
dass wir da sind
continuum gesperrt das drumherum wie ich
alles schuhen und darf einfach nicht
gehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]